well first up he's a professor of
sociology at georgetown university whose
latest book is tears we cannot stop a
sermon to white america michael eric
dyson
[Music]
you've sat in this chair before when you
were the newsmaker unfortunately this
week i find i'm the newsmaker
i wanted you to come by here because you
know i want you to to
to school me
uh i did a bad thing yeah well that's a
great place to begin
bill very bad thing yeah um but look
in the past you've been the person who
has been on the front line saying that
the left shouldn't apologize
progressives should resist any sense of
complicity with a culture that is too
apologetic and yet you find yourself on
the hot seat here tonight uh what led to
that change of mind
oh and i thought you were going to be
easy on me uh
and you shouldn't no that i mean that's
true but you know honestly i've said
both i mean i i have um i remember when
mitt romney was running he had a book no
apologies
you know like america should never
apologize and i said no apologies are
sometimes appropriate there is a lot of
[ __ ] apologizing in america and i am
against that uh but you know we
shouldn't apologize for slavery and
japanese internment and abu ghraib and
indian genocide and tuskegee
right so when it's appropriate this was
appropriate because i'll tell you why
because for for black folks that word
i don't care who you are right has
caused pain i'm not here to do that
right now
the guy who was here it's not his fault
i feel bad about him the senator um it's
all on me but he said a weird thing
the comic mind
goes to a weird place sometimes but
doesn't it doesn't matter that it wasn't
said in malice it wasn't it if it
brought back pain to people right well
but then i and that's why i apologize
freely and i reiterate it tonight well
that's sincere right
but look
but
you're used to those cheers that big of
an ass all right
well you use those chairs but you got to
understand now you know i'm taking a lot
of heat people saying you're a [ __ ]
you're a sellout why would you dare go
on uh the show with your guy who's your
friend because they feel good they
figure that i'm going to be complicit
with you that i'm not going to challenge
you that this is an easy pass but do you
understand why people are skeptical in
the pain and the suffering look when you
made the point about the house
in and then you you know black people
were saying look it's not as if black
people in the house were any better off
than people in the field both of them
were subject to slave dominance hegemony
hatred rape and the like and as a result
of that okay as a result of that people
think that that's insensitive
but surely you must know all that was
not going on in my mind
right well of course and as far as your
question about you're gonna look i know
we're friends right
and that is not a greater bond
than your bond with the black community
i hope we're friends forever but anyone
who knows you knows you're a straight
shooter right uh i mean i feel like i
got robert mueller here
you know right i got so you know i what
let me ask you this so one of the things
that
you know my book the book you mentioned
is about white privilege i talk a lot
about white privilege when i was here
before i spoke about that and people
believe that one of the things you did
last week was an unconscious reflex
nobody will describe to you any
malicious intent but that's the point
right that it grows out of a culture
that reflexively identifies uh that
particular word with some heinous acts
in history and so they think it's a
matter of privilege that it doesn't
happen let me let me read you something
that my son a well-known authority uh on
this he's this is what he texted me
he said i know white boys like that who
get a pass who earn a pass from the work
they put in but the coolest and most
honorable white boys are the ones that
choose not to act on that past because
they understand the history pain and
insensitivity behind the use of the
n-word so do you do you truly understand
the the need to name and to challenge
that unconscious
white privilege that exists and how it
hurts black people even if
unintentionally yeah but
of course i i think i do i mean we're
all evolving
we're all who we are right by the way
this happened once right a guy said a
weird thing i made a bad joke right yes
it was wrong and i own up to that right
but i mean it's not like i've made a
career of this right right you know it's
not like i went out there last last
friday and said oh i'm going to break
some new ground tonight right right
right it you know it happened and it was
wrong and people make mistakes we're all
sinners and we gotta yeah
so but but i totally get that uh look i
mean we we are all evolving right at the
pace of day by day i grew up
in an all-white town yeah in new jersey
right not alabama right that's the
country i this was i was born in 1956
i grew up in new jersey in the 50s and
60s and
race wasn't even an issue
it didn't exist right we were except my
parents
told me the right thing about it right
and i've tried to by the way portray the
right thing about it well there's no
question about that i've said that's why
i'm here that's why i'm here there's no
question
but here
but here's the issue you just put your
you just put your finger on an extremely
important point so that those people
over there right we think about in the
age of trump we think about the
nefarious uh resurgence of racism under
jeff sessions and under steve bannon
there's no question about that so that
even if your intent is certainly not to
to cause any kind of pain or horror you
do know that the use of that word then
triggered i think the not only the
unconscious but the but the way in which
black people feel on their hunches now
because of the resurgence of racism that
you but that the reason i'm here is
because you have attacked that you you
are the one who said denying racism is
the new racism you're the one who called
donald trump out on his racism and
forced him to show his birth certificate
but what's what's interesting and tricky
here is that when i talk about white
privilege in my book i talk about people
who are consciously the allies of black
people but who may also inadvertently
unintentionally but nonetheless lethally
participate in the culture that ends up
hurting as you've acknowledged black
people uh in a way that has to be
grappled with that's why i think there
was so much outrage and hurt and pain
people don't think oh bill maher is a
racist i don't think most people thought
that what they thought was if even bill
maher
can at some level capitulate to a level
of unconscious privilege then the rest
of us are in a in a serious spot okay
but
but i'm not here to make excuses
but first of all the word is
omnipresent in the culture yeah so the
fact that it was in my mind is you know
also
is there what part of what you're saying
true absolutely as i said i'm just a
product of the country like everybody
else right but i just don't want to
pretend this is
more of a race thing than a comedian
thing
comedians
are a special kind of monkey
so to speak
we are
[Laughter]
[ __ ] with me
[Laughter]
we are a trained
thing that tries to get a laugh that's
that's what we do that's all we are
always thinking right and this is not
the first time this has happened first
time on this subject but not the first
time i've gotten in trouble in private
as well as in public because that's what
comedians are somehow wired to do is
like always go we want to make those
people laugh right and sometimes we
transgress a sensitivity point i mean my
friend kathy griffin yeah
who by the way owes me
uh a fruit basket for getting her off
the front pitch yeah
no doubt about that
but you know there's a there's a a
similarity there because like
what she did
as much as i hate trump yeah that's
wrong you don't do that to whoever the
president is right
but
you know she was going for a laugh right
and i understand that we sometimes do
cross the line where i i you know where
i want to just wanted to say to her is
she said trump broke me
no he shouldn't and my career is over no
it's not right you make a mistake you
don't have to go away right everyone
makes mistakes no no question about that
let me say this kathy griffin should not
go away no no you know i talk in this
book and i think you and i have talked
about this offline uh that when i first
heard [ __ ] said to me i was a
seven-year-old child uh with my friends
in the south i reread it this week i
mean i felt even worse i mean look and
it's real because that kind of crashing
consciousness that i am different that i
am forever consigned to a different box
relegated to a different reality so that
even with i think you're absolutely
right in terms of the comedic line you
know what people would respond to that
by saying but look there are trigger
points even in comedy that lines you
should not cross as you said kathy
should not do and when it comes to race
you know that i mean it's not that i'm
introducing a new concept to you you
understand that but the reality is that
there are so many people who are
vulnerable out here who are black people
brown people red and yellow people who
are vulnerable who don't have the
protection of a culture so that their
comedians might make jokes think about
it uh i i thought about larry larry to
look you remember larry david um one of
my favorite scenes from curb your
enthusiasm is when a black man comes up
to him and says hey you my [ __ ] and
larry david wants to show affection so
he wants to go you're my
he says are you are you my caucasian
so
so what he understood what he understood
was that's a lie he can't cross and
because he understands he can't cross it
even his comedy has to be disciplined by
it now now as you've already said the
reason i'm here wait a minute the reason
i'm here is because i'm willing to take
the heat for people because i think that
the bill maher i know has been on the
front line protecting
standing up standing up
for
four people
you made a mistake you've acknowledged
that mistake and i think it's important
for the nation not to rush past that but
to understand that even as
celebrated and as conscientious a figure
as you if you can make a mistake that
means the rest of us can so we have to
grapple with how deeply rooted that is
so for me look i know you're not a
christian and you're an atheist and i'm
a christian but i tell people often i'd
rather work with you as an atheist
because you ultimately believe in the
principles of justice but my bible tells
me to whom much is given much is
required you've been given a great deal
and as a result of the great deal that
you've been given i want to see you
continue to stand up and trumpet justice
for those who are vulnerable to
reinforce their standing in a culture
where you've gone after the powerful and
done it in such a powerful way that's
why i text you often every week after
the show and say bill you got in their
faces again and in getting in their
faces again that means standing with
those who are vulnerable to those who
are who are who are
look i mean
[Applause]
every quarterback throws an interception
no doubt no doubt and i try to squeeze
him in yeah more than most yeah yeah you
bart you're brett farving the game there
yeah
well
i'm just saying you know what what
bothered me about this is that i i i
it's it cost me a lot of political
capital you know i'll use that term
even though i'm a comedian but i'm a
comedian who's doing something a little
different than most which is of course
i'm trying to entertain and be popular
that's my political capital right but at
the same time i'm saying things that are
sometimes unpopular even with my own
liberal group yes which most people
don't yeah so i'm always you know
aware of like well i'm willing to do
that i'm willing to spend political
capital for a cause or a view
that i think needs to be out there right
this wasn't that this was just a mistake
all right this was just a dumb
interception you know right well no so
you know but again i've been on 24 years
right
well there's no question and and but and
the thing is it's not
as i said
as i said you know that this would be a
teachable moment it is a teachable
moment because you happen to be the kind
of person whose conscience causes you to
be reflective there's so many more
millions of people who exercise white
privilege without any sense of
consciousness and who refuses to own up
to that in a way and i think whether or
not you intended that to be the case it
at least opens up the possibility that
we can have that conversation and i
think that's a consequence you mentioned
a few minutes ago the fact that i
introduced that phrase into the language
yes denying racism is the new racism yes
i mean a vast majority of fox news
viewers
think racism doesn't exist right that
we've made it up
that we've made and that the real
problem is reverse racism absolutely i
mean there's a lot of work to do and
your book talks about what let's get to
what people can really
do because you talk about reparations
and you talk about reading right right
just it's the time we have left tell us
about those two things well i think
they're important and you know when i
talk about reparations i'm not saying
that every white person should give
their money to black people though after
the show if anybody is willing to do
that
i certainly want to be available uh but
i'm talking about practical things let
me tell you what some people some white
folk read my book and wrote me and said
look i took you seriously i went out and
bought some some computers that were
that were tore up that were jacked up i
got them fixed i took 20 computers over
to the local school with
african-american people and you should
and they sent me the pictures of them
and it was incredible so those are the
kind of practical things practical
wisdom practical justice that can be
rendered in the name of that and then
reading read look look all of us need to
deepen our awareness of what's going on
as you know bill i mean and you'll have
that conversation later black people
ourselves are at war with each other
about whether we use the n word or not
some people think we should some people
think we shouldn't uh i'm not a racial
loyalist in the sense of i believe we
should be fundamentally aligned to a
certain position that says if you
believe this and you're legitimate
you're black and if not you don't i
don't believe in that i believe in the
same kind of thing you believe in the
kind of irreverence but having said that
what i also understand is that reading
and engaging the world around us you're
learning something about the world
before you so many people speak about
race and they have racial amnesia they
have they're they're caught in a fog of
dismemory they want to see the world the
way they want to see it they listen to
fox all day long they believe that the
president is the greatest man i'm
talking about the present president uh
in the history of the world and what
they fail to understand is that this new
age in which we live
has certified and legitimated the
resurgence of some of the most heinous
expressions of anti-blackness that we've
seen and we need you as an ally and i'm
glad we got you brother doctor professor
all right
jason